bu monono VR diye bir söylemle başlamak
istiyorum Bu aslında Japonca bir söylem
hayatın geçiciliği ne ve hayatın
geçiciliğini yarattığı Hüsnü ifade eden
bir söylem çok güzel bir ifade edebilir
bizi Aslında eskilerin dediği gibi bir
perspektifte de hayat Fani diyor Şimdi
Hayat geçici ise biz bu geçiciliğin Ve
dahi kısalığının ne kadar farkındayız bu
çok temel bir soru Aslında bugünkü
konuşmanın amacı birçok TED konuşmasında
olduğu gibi sizlerin hayatınıza entegre
edebileceğiniz
bu doğru farkındalık ve fikir pH'ı
kırıntılarını zevk etmek Onun için
Aslında ben bugün size çok havalı
slaytlar ya da milyonlarca kere izlenmiş
ve çok iyi bildiğiniz keyifli videoları
izle etmeyeceğim Sadece mümkün olduğunca
Gerçeklerden bahsetmeye çalışacağım
gerçekler de bildiğiniz üzere biraz can
acıtabilir veya rahatsız edebilir Evet
tekrar dönelim farkında mıyız bu
geçiciliğin demiştik Aslında her şey
soru sormakla sorgulamakla başlıyor
Çünkü her soru sormuş aslında bir Arayış
ve soru sordukça Bizim hem zihnimiz hem
aklımız hem Kalbimiz hem de
farkındalığımızı Zinde kalıyor ve
Diyoruz ki aslında farkında mısın
bu sanal ve suni ilik kavramların altını
boşaltmaya başladı ve kavramları
gerçeklikten kop atmaya başladı
kavramları gerçeklikten kop artmaya
başladıkça karşınıza İmaj ve fantazi nin
etkinliğinin daha yükseldiğini görmeye
başladık ve bununla birlikte kavramların
altı daha fazla boşaldı ve bir nevi
felsefesiz leşme çağır yaşıyoruz sadece
bununla da kalmıyor aslında hiç bu kadar
özgür olmadığımız bir çağdayız çok
Özgürüz ama bir taraftan baktığımızda da
hiç bu kadar yalnız yetersiz ve aciz de
hissetmemiş tik Çünkü dikkatimizi
dönüştürürken kendimize Hiç acımıyor Uz
ve kendimizi çok kolay harcıyoruz ve her
yere dikkatimizi hunharca dağıta
biliyoruz
ama sonuçta burada baktığınızda
ilizyonun sanal insanların sanal
duyguların sanal mekanların sanal
davranışların sanal ilişkilerin sanal
aşkın sana sevişmelerin veya sanal
olarak travmaların ve daha nice sanal
ların ne kadar farkındayız Ve bu sanal
larla yaşadığımız iz yolun asla ne kadar
farkındayız
de diyebilirsiniz ki Ne olacak yani
tamam farkında değilim ya da farkındayım
Çok da umrumda değil
bu burada Aslında farkındalık ya da
farkında olmaktan ziyade ne yapacağımız
çok kritik ve şu da söyleyebiliriz
farkındayım Ya da değilim ama en
nihayetinde bir şey olmaz Ben iyiyim
Evet iyisin çok iyisin Hatta Süpersin
fevkalbeşer sin eskilerin deyimiyle yani
süper bir insansın Peki süper insan yani
eskilerin deyimiyle fevkalbeşer nasıl
bir insan bakalım
ilk öncelikle App fazla farkındalığı
olmayan bir insan
ve akabinde mutlaka her şeyi çok iyi
bilen bir insan
he has kovalayan ve sürekli kısa vadeli
anlık keyifler peşinde koşan insan anı
yaşayan andan keyif almaya bakan bir
insan
bu dinlemeyen sürekli konuşan anlatan
bir insan
o kendi İmajını yöneten ve yönetmekle
alakalı da çabalayan bir insan
ve hayatının merkezinde performans olan
ve sürekli o performans perspektifinde
başarıyı kovalayan insan ve en
nihayetinde kendine hayran mı insan ses
süper bir insan asla baktığınızda şimdi
Abi şu diyebilirsiniz ben böyle bir
insan değilim Olabilir Peki Acaba böyle
bir insan değilseniz Arafta mısınız Ne
demek ağrap arada kalmak demek neyin
arasında kalmak sanalla yani ilizyonla
gerçeklik arasında kalmak O zaman belki
de Arif insanısınız yani Arada kalmış
bir insansınız ilizyonla gerçekliğin
arasında kalmış bir insan peki o nasıl
bir insan
da kısmi olarak farkında olan bir insan
tek bildikleri kadar bilmedikleri de
olan ve bunu bilen bir insan
he has kovalarken arada sorgulaya bilen
anlamarama ya da Derdi olan insan on anı
sürekli yaşarken arada andan şöyle
Kafasını kaldırıp topa bilen insan
sen dinlen ama dinlediğini sallamayan
yani aksiyon almayan insan İmajını
yöneten ama Man niye yapıyorum ben bu
işleri diye arada sorgulayan insan
o Ekmek gayemiz En nihayetinde geçim
için her türlü performans odaklayım
diyen insan
bu maalesef kendini çok sevmeyen sevmek
isteyen ama sevemeyen acı çeken kendine
ezikleyen insan
ve yine şu diyebilirsiniz ben bu insan
değilim Evet olabilir belki daha farklı
bir Eksen misiniz belki de kalemler
meşrepsiz ne demek kalemler sende eski
kelimeleri buluyorsun Kalender ve
kalemler insan demek aslında rafine
insan demek ne demek rafine İnsan biraz
ona bakalım
bu farkındalığı olan insan
ve bilmediğini bilen ve veya haddini
bilen insan
ve benliğini egosunu yöneten insan
ve sorgulayan
bu ve sürekli soru sormaktan korkmayan
ve sorunun bir arayış olduğunu bilen
insan
bu dertlenen hayatla ilgili kendi ile
ilgili çevresindekilerle ilgili
yaptıkları ile ilgili dertlere insan
ve tevazu sahibi yani mütevazı bir insan
sen dinlen dinledikleri perspektifinde
de
bu aksiyon alabilen bir insan
ne anlam peşinde koşan hayatı anlama
Derdi olan ve anlamları hayatında daha
önemli olan insan
ve en nihayetinde de gerçekliği yaşayan
insan
ve yine ne şunu diyebilirsiniz beni
kategorize etme şu insan bu insan şu
kategori bu kategori
bu Peki sen kimsin kim olduğunu biliyor
musun daha da önemli soru biliyor musun
bilmek Aslında çok değerli bir kavram
Peki ne demek bilmek bilmek gerçeğin
kendisine aşkla aramak demek
bu ve Aslında baktığınızda bilme eylemi
ve kavramı da bir Arayışın sonucunda
hayatımıza çıkan bir şey ve bu arayış
Yani bu serüven esnasında üç tane farklı
aktörle karşılaşıyoruz birinci aktör
Bilgiç Bilgiç bilgiyi Aslında
baktığınızda kendi çıkarları
doğrultusunda kullanan Bilgiden değer
elde eden bilginin artistliği yapan
bir kişi ve Sözde bilgi olan kişi
aslında baktığımızda Bilgiç Bilgin ise
O bizim sahibi ve 20 ile alakalı
ziyadesiyle donanımlı insan eskilerin
Alim dediği
bir bilgi ise İrfan sahibi yani
düşüncelerini duygularıyla harmanlamış
insan eskilerin Arif dediği Şimdi
aslında baktığınızda bilgi serüveninde
üç tane farklı personel var ve biz
bilgiyi ne kadar hayatımızda kanımıza
karıştırırsak yani hayatımızın protein
de bilgiyle kadar donanımlı ve Yetkin
bir şekilde kullanırsak o kadar doğru
şekilde hayatımızı yaşayabiliyoruz peki
bu bilgiyi bilme bu süreçte ne demiştik
Gerçeğin ta kendisini aşkla aramak
demiştik neden aşktan bahsettik Çünkü
bizim hayatta ne istediğimizi ne
yapacağımızı Neyi yaptığımızı ya da neye
tutkumuz olduğunu bize söyleyen şey
aslında Aşkın kendisine Aşık sınız Neyi
yaptığınızda kalbiniz daha farklı atıyor
işte bunu bulmak çok kritik bir şey
çünkü bu sizin tutkus ve tutkunuzu da
gerçekten hakkıyla bulduğunuz zaman o
zaman başarı geliyor ve başarının
başarılı olan bir perspektifte Aşksız ve
tutkusuz kesinlikle herhangi bir şey
gerçekleşmiyor Onun için mutlak bir
başarı istiyorsak herhangi bir alanda
mutlaka o alanın
O bizim tutkumuz lawaia aşkımızda
kesişmesi gerekiyor tek başına Aşk
Yeterli bir konumu değil Çünkü senin
tutkunu hayata geçirmek için yada Tutkun
da ilerleyebilmek için tutkunla alakalı
dertlenmeyen gerekiyor Hatta tutkunu
takıntı haline getirecek kadar
dertlenmeyen gerekiyor ve Sen aşkı doğru
dertlenme motivasyonu ile Harmanlar San
İşte o zaman yine başarı geliyor ve
bugün baktığınızda az önce bahsettiğimiz
o samanlık sunnilik perspektifinde
dertlenen insanı çok az görüyoruz
dertlenmek sadece İşiyle alakalı
dertlenmek değil arkadaşıyla sevdiğiyle
çocuğuyla ailesiyle alakalı dertlenmek
hayatta alakalı dertlenmek toplumsal
konularla alakalı dertlenmek ve
dertlenmek gerçekten insanı in
bu yapan en önemli erdemlerden biri
bu peki çok güzel bunlardan
bahsediyorsun
ya bu kadar kauçuk bir ortamda bizim
güvene ihtiyacınız olan bu kadar kaosu
içerisinde kendimizi gerçekleştirme
ihtiyacımız olan bir ortamda ne yapmamız
gerekiyor bununla güzel anlatıyorsun da
neler somut neler yapmak lazım Bunları
da bir 20 maddede hızlıca toparlamak
istiyorum birincisi aşktan çok bahsettim
Onun için birinci maddeye onunla
başlamak istiyorum mutlaka aşık
olacaksın kalbini fark edeceksin Çünkü
az önce
bu bilginin tanımını bilginin tanımını
yaparken düşüncelerini duygularıyla
harmanlamış insan dedim Çünkü duygularla
harmanlanmış düşünce her zaman eksiktir
Onun için duygunu kalbini hissetmek
dünyanın en ileri teknolojilerin de
yapay zekanın zirveye çıktığı dönemde
bile hala insan duyguları insan
duygularıyla alakalı değerlendirmeler ve
aksiyonlar değerini koruyor ve
koruyacaktır ve daha da artacaktır iki
dertli olacaksın acı çekeceksin derdin
ne alakalı şu düzgün tasar olacak acı
çekmek çok kötü bir şey değil ünlü Alman
Filozofu Haydi gel der ki insan dünyaya
fırlatılmıştır fırlatılmış olduğu andan
itibaren de dünyaya hüzünle ve acıyla
Bakar ama bu acı bu Hüzün onu geliştirir
Ama bunlar Tabii ki yetmiyor şu sabırlı
olacaksın işinle alakalı ve Sebat
edeceksin ki bu yine şu anda
baktığımızda en zor olan konulardan biri
Çünkü biz çok kısa anlık takvimleri
yaşadığımız için hızlıca Evet bir
sonraki hemen bir an önce müdür olayım
bir an önce zengin olayım bir an önce
Türkiye'nin en iyisi olayım ama en
nihayetinde her şeyi başarabilmek için
baz bir sabır baz bir Sebat gerekiyor
Hangi iş hangi alan ne olursa olsun
kendini insanı
bu hayatı ve gerçekten kitabı
okuyacaksın elinden kitabı eksik
etmeyeceksin hangi konuda olursa olsun
çünkü bugün okuma bilmeyen insan bu
anlattığım Türk kavramları çok uzak
insandır okumayı tekrar söylüyorum
Sadece düz kitap okuma olarak düşünmeyin
kendini okuyan hayatı okuyan insan
okuyan insan her zaman fark yaratır
ben yalnız kalmayı
o kalınca da kendinle kalmayı
becerebilecek misin yine Bugünlerde en
zorlandığımız konulardan biri yalnız
kalabilmek yalnız kalabilmek telefonunla
yalnız kalmak değil gerçekten kendine
yalnız kalabilmek derdin ne acı ne
sıkıntı ve neden mutlusun neden
mutsuzsun kendinde Ne istiyorsun Ne
istemiyorsun bunları konuşabilmek
kendinle dertleş e bilmek çok değerli
Onun için yalnız kalmayı becerebilmek de
çok değerli
Ne hazırlığı değil hedeflere uzak
duracaksın ki en nihayetinde hayatla
ilgili Maddi manevi hedeflerin olmalı ve
o hedefler doğrultusunda hareket etmesin
hazlara gittiğin zaman hazların sonu yok
hazla sonsuz ve anlık olarak hayatında
sürekli tükettiği şeyler Elbette bunları
yapacaksın ama hedefler daha Öncelikle
gelmek koşuluyla nefes alacaksın Ben
nefes almayı bileceksin sana iyi gelen
sana nefes aldıran ortamlar mekanlar
insanlar muhabbetler okumalar izlemeler
dinlemeler Neyse kendi nefes alma
matematiğini çözüp nefes almayı asla
unutmayacaksın Çünkü bir şeyler
yapabilmek için sürekli nefes alabilmek
kafayı kaldırabilmek için çok Elzem Lig
olur
de aklımda Kalbine ve manayı bile maddi
iyiden geleceksin az önce söylediğim
duyguyla düşünceyi harmanlama hikayesi
akışı kapılmayacaksın kendi akışına
sahip olacaksın şu anda baktığınızda
Hepiniz çok büyük bir akışı
içerisindeyiz ve hızla akıp gidiyoruz
ama buradaki kritik konu kendi akışı ne
kendi akışında oluştura bildin mi ve
büyük akışın içerisinde benim durduğum
yer neresi bunu tanımlamak çok kritik
disiplinli ve sistematik olacaksın en az
üç şiiri ezbere bileceksin bu da hayatı
yaşanılır kılmak için önemli bir şey ve
birkaç manzara ile karşılaştığında
aklına birkaç ressamın tablolarını
getireceksin Bu da çok değerli Çünkü o
manzarayı aksi taktirde nasıl keyifli
bakasın ki ve o ressamlar
bu kabloları eserleri Bu farkındalığı da
bizim için bizi zenginleştirecek bir
otur hiç gitmediğin ortamlara gidip hiç
tanışmam dediğin insanlarla tanışacaksın
Çünkü diyalog dediğin şey sosyal medyada
olduğu gibi Sevdiğin ve benzer ilgi
alanına benzer görüşe sahip olduğun
insanlarla muhabbet demek değildir
diyalog dediğin şey senden farklı olan
insanlarla Aslında muhabbet edip seni
geliştiren bir şeydir Dolayısıyla Yine
bize o sana aldın yarattığı iz yolu
gerçek hayatta mümkün olduğunca farklı
perspektifler L kırmak gerekiyor
yaşadığı şehirde yemeğin yüzeyini yapan
yerleri bileceksin Bu da senin Aslında
hayat bu son için önemli bir şey ya da
hiç gitmediğim bir şehre gidip turist
gibi değil Seyyah gibi gelecek
Evet şimdi son slayt ta bazı şeyleri
anlamak için Ekstra dertlenmek gerekiyor
bence bunları cebimize koymamız
gerekiyor veya bir bilezik gibi takmamız
gerekiyor nedir bunlar artık bugünün
dünyasında matematik Algoritma Psikoloji
Sosyoloji tarih antropoloji hikaye
anlatımı Bunları gerçekten anlamış Ve
kana karıştırmış olmamız gerekiyor ve bu
konularla ilgileniyorsanız hayatın
farkındalığı ile alakalı
ilgileniyorsanız bazı adamları ya da
kadınları okumakta fayda var ve onun
haricindeki insanları da okumakta fayda
var okumak en nihayetinde önemli ve
mutlaka bazı yerlere gitmek lazım
cenazesi Hastanesi kadın günü
kahvehanesi huzur evi Müzesi veya pazarı
hayatın gerçek
bu aktığı yerlerde vakit geçirmek
gerekiyor ki biz de gerçeklerin izi
koruyabilirim ne denk açmamız gerekiyor
bazı şeyler denk açmamız gerekiyor nedir
bunlar gerçekliği olmayan insanlar EGO
sahte ortamda sanal alemi vizyonu sanal
duygular ve sanal tavırlar bunlardan da
mümkün olduğunca kaçmak gerekiyor Şu son
olarak Bakın bu Kitabe ders kitabının
ağında milattan önce yedinci yüzyılda
Aslında oluşturulmuş bir kitabı ve
milattan önce yedinci yüzyıldan beri
insanoğlunun derdi kendini olmak Yani
Aslında Hala biz kendimiz olmaya
çalışıyoruz ve tümbal attıkları
perspektifinde de son madde olarak
mümkün olduğunca kendin oluyorum ve
hepinize teşekkür ederim
abone ol